MICHELLE WILLIAMS:
Welcome to The Forum,
live streamed worldwide
from the Leadership Studio
at the Harvard TH Chan
School of Public Health.
I'm Dean Michelle Williams.
The Forum is a collaboration
between the Harvard Chan School
and independent news media.
Each program features
a panel of experts
addressing some of today's most
pressing public health issues.
The Forum is one way
the school advances
the frontiers of
public health and makes
scientific insights accessible
to policymakers and the public.
I hope you find this program
engaging and informative.
Thank you for joining us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHILLIP MARTIN: Well,
welcome, everyone.
This is going to be an
extraordinary discussion
and one that is timely,
to say the least.
My name is Phillip Martin.
I'm a senior investigative
reporter with WGBH in Boston
and also contribute to The
World, PRI's The World.
And I'm today's moderator.
Our panelists starting
from my immediate right
here are Oren Segal.
He's the director of the
Anti-Defamation League
Center on Extremism.
We also have David Williams,
my friend David Williams,
who's been on the panel with me,
or I've been on panel with him
several times.
He's the chair of the Department
of Social and Behavioral
Sciences at the Harvard
Chan School here.
We have Dipayan Ghosh, who is
a fellow at the Harvard Kennedy
School and an expert
on social media.
We'll be talking about that.
Maureen Costello, all the way in
from Montgomery and Birmingham,
Alabama, director of
Teaching Tolerance
and member of the Southern
Poverty Law Center's
senior leadership team.
And my friend joining
us remotely again,
Jim Doyle, former
senior Menschel fellow
and former governor
and Attorney General
of Wisconsin, a state that's
really in the news these days,
isn't it?
This event is being presented
jointly with PRI's The World
and WGBH.
And we're streaming live.
Just want everyone to
get to your Facebook
and your social media
because we're streaming live
on Facebook and YouTube.
This program will include
brief questions and answers.
And you folks, you
can email questions
to theforum@hsph.harvard.edu.
I'm going to repeat that again--
theforum@hsph.harvard.edu.
And you can also
participate in a live chat
that's happening on The Forum
site at this very moment.
We've seen it.
All you have to do is
turn on your television,
turn on your radio.
You've heard people
and seen people
marching in Virginia shouting,
"The Jews will not replace us."
We've seen a synagogue
where a massacre took place.
We saw supermarket-- people
going out shopping and shot
to death because of the
color of their skin.
Acts of hate and racism,
whether online or in person,
are painfully
visible these days.
Statistics from
the FBI, as well as
from organizations such as
the Southern Poverty Law
Center and the
Anti-Defamation League,
confirm that hate
crimes are on the rise.
Such acts are, of course, not
only in the United States.
We see this in Europe and
other places globally.
Just take a look at
the streets of Poland.
Or look at Hungary or the
Philippines or Brazil.
And you see what they have in
common besides the populism--
that is the term of choice--
is a lot of hate.
And today, during Black
History Month, we pause.
We take a moment to ask,
what forces are fueling
the rise of hate and racism?
What's contributing to
what we're seeing out here?
And what can we do about it?
That's the operative question.
To give us a snapshot
of one disconcerting
facet of extremism,
let's just take a look
at a clip from the
Anti-Defamation League.
This clip illustrates
the explosive growth
of white supremacist
propaganda on college campuses.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm going to turn
to Oren right now.
Oren, your organization's
been tracking--
looking at the data for years.
What exactly is going on?
I've seen posters, for
example, at local colleges
in Boston of basically
where folks have essentially
been recruiting.
Can you talk about
what the data shows
and how you've been tracking
these organizations?
OREN SEGAL: Sure.
So at ADL, we're tracking
both extremist-related data,
but also hate incidents and
hate crimes of all types.
And I think the discussion
today about what
is driving hate and racism and
what we can do about it really
needs to start with the data.
So what I'd like to do is
just provide some of that.
FBI hate crime
statistics recently
came out for 2017,
which demonstrated
a 17% increase in hate
crimes around the country.
That was over 7,000
incidents that were reported.
Now one of the key pieces
of data that, I think,
was not necessarily
underscored but is as critical
is that in over 90 cities with
people that have over 100,000
in population either
reported zero hate crimes
or didn't report
hate crimes at all.
So even that number,
we know, is much lower.
At ADL, we also track
anti-Semitic incidents, not
just crimes but other forms of
harassment and intimidation.
And in 2017, we
saw a 57% increase
in those anti-Semitic incidents
from the previous year.
And that included
an over 90% increase
in just k-through-12
through 12 schools.
Right, our kids are watching
the public discussion.
They are viewing how the
headlines on the news
and in your newspapers and
on your social media feed
are constantly filled
with hate and extremism.
And the last point about this
to the video that we just saw,
we've actually seen a 500%
increase in white supremacist
propaganda on the ground.
Not just college campuses
where we saw a spike
and we continue to
see that increase.
But what that means is
this post-Charlottesville
environment that we're
in, white supremacists
may not be as comfortable
showing their faces at a rally.
But what they're doing are
finding other clandestine ways
to amplify and spread their
messages through propaganda
spread out not only
in small towns,
but literally in every
major city that we see.
And last point, we also track
extremist-related murders
at ADL, and we've been
doing so since about 1970.
2018 was the fourth
deadliest year related
to extremist-related murders.
We saw over 50 people
killed by extremists,
and 98% of those were by
right-wing extremists--
white supremacists,
antigovernment types.
And when you look at
the past 10 years,
of all the extremist-related
murders-- about 427--
73% have been carried
out by white supremacists
and other homegrown
antigovernment type extremists.
That may not necessarily connect
with some of the narratives
we hear in the news every day.
But these are the statistics
we need to account for
as we have this discussion about
whether hate is rising or not.
PHILLIP MARTIN: I'd like to
see how those statistics also
connect with David
Harris's research.
David, your work
is evidence-based,
as you've described it.
You've studied how
discrimination,
including racist
language and attitudes
on prejudice, the effects
of health of those
who are in the crosshairs.
You've talked about that impact.
Tell us more about
what you and what
your colleagues have found.
DAVID WILLIAMS: Well, there's
a large body of research--
and it's a global
body of research--
that indicates that
exposure to discrimination,
both kind of virulent
forms but even little
indignities on a
day to day basis,
has pervasive adverse
negative effects on health.
There's studies
showing an increase
in the risk of
premature death linked
to exposure to discrimination.
What the research
is also showing us
that is very relevant
for our conversation,
that it's not just
the incidents that are
targeted at you individually.
But if you live in a
community with higher levels
of prejudice, studies
show African Americans who
live in such communities
across the United States,
such counties across
the United States
have higher rates of death.
It's not just African Americans.
There's a study looking
at anti-gay prejudice
in the United States.
And for LGBT populations
who live in communities
of higher anti-gay
prejudice, their death rates
are three times
higher than those
who live in communities of low
levels of anti-gay prejudice.
And this is pervasive
throughout society.
One of the studies
I was involved with
documented that among high
school and middle school
students who are exposed
to racial discrimination
in online contexts,
their levels of anxiety,
their levels of
depression are higher,
even after you take into account
other adolescent stresses
and discrimination offline.
So documenting the
discrimination online
is a unique contributor
to their poor health.
There's research documenting
the negative effects
of anti-immigrant rhetoric, but
also anti-immigrant policies.
So for example, a
study I was involved
with in the state of
Arizona after SB1070
was passed, a law
that authorized
local officials to
stop anyone who looked
as if they might be illegal.
And we documented among
Mexican American mothers,
there was a decrease in the
use of preventive health
services for their children and
the access of social services.
And most strikingly
in that study,
that effect was strongest among
US-born Mexican American women.
So those women who were
citizens of the United States,
we suspect, were so--
it was such an assault
to their dignity
that they could be stopped
simply because of how
they looked that there was
these negative effects.
And there's research
documenting that--
a study out of Los Angeles
that shows 11th graders who,
in the year before
the election, were
concerned about the hate and the
discrimination in the society.
A year later, they have
higher levels of depression,
higher levels of anxiety, higher
levels of substance abuse.
So the bottom line
is we are finding
pervasive negative
effects on the health
of multiple stigmatized
populations linked
to the exposure, not only
the personal targeting
but this broader context of
hostility in our environment.
PHILLIP MARTIN: One thing
is this conversation
is such that, no, we
don't have to struggle
to connect the dots between
your different expertise.
Dipayan, something David
just talked about--
the role of online
media, the role
of social media in promulgating
hate is fairly clear right now.
But you've done
research on this topic.
What have been your findings?
DIPAYAN GHOSH: Well,
I think both Oren's
and David's comments and
yours really resonate for me.
When we think about
some of the memes that
have risen over
the past few years
or even particular
instances of hate-- so,
for example, the frog
meme or instances
of hate against particular
classes of the US population
really pushed by others groups.
The thing that we really
have to think about
is, why is this happening?
What is the infrastructure
that is enabling
the spread and the
pervasiveness, as David
has suggested, of all of
this content being consumed?
Why is it having such an
impact on the internet?
And what I'd suggest is that
it is about the infrastructure.
It is about the
commercial regime
that sits behind these
internet platforms,
from YouTube to Facebook
to Twitter to even
some of the newer platforms.
And when we think about
that infrastructure,
it's sometimes difficult to get
our heads around how it works
and what connects them all
and how they're all similar.
But deep down, I think
that infrastructure,
that commercial
regime that defines
these platforms is actually
fairly simple at a high level.
First of all, these
platforms, they
develop very
compelling services--
like Messenger or like the News
Feed or like the Twitter feed
or like the YouTube system--
to such an extent that
they're, as some psychologists
have suggested, addictive.
And this has prevented
other services
from actually challenging
these services to the extent
that they're limiting
competition on the internet.
Second, through
these services that
are dominating the
internet, these companies
are drawing up--
hoovering up large
amounts of data
of our personal information
through our engagement
on the News Feed, as
well as through purchases
of data from third parties,
as well as from third party
websites to develop
behavioral profiles on us.
And those first
two pillars move us
to the third, which is that
these companies develop
very precise and sophisticated
algorithms that do two things--
curate content in our social
feeds and target ads at us
based on our behavioral profile
and based on our extensive use
of these platforms.
And so what I'd suggest is that
this infrastructure has grown
up in this way for
20 years, as we've
seen Facebook and Google come to
the fore in the global economy,
and really taken over the
internet commercially,
to the extent that these impacts
against hate are not really--
these companies are
not really challenged
from a business perspective
to do anything about it
until and unless the
public sentiment rises up
so much that they have to
actually start to address it.
What I'd suggest is that we
draw on the tremendous public
sentiment against hate, against
the spread of disinformation,
against the spread of
algorithmic discrimination
and take this opportunity
in the next couple of years
to push a regime, a regulatory
regime that addresses
the harms of that business
model so that we have better
competition on the internet, so
that we have better privacy, so
that we can have
better transparency
and to the ways that
these algorithms work.
And what I'd
suggest is that that
can start to address
in the long run
this spread of hate issue, which
is really, really challenging
us in really difficult ways.
PHILLIP MARTIN: OK.
The online content
that you, Oren--
David Williams
have talked about--
this stuff, of course, is
being consumed by everyone.
It's across the board.
But it's mainly being
consumed by young people
when you talk about
online platforms.
And we talk about
Teaching Tolerance,
both the name of
the organization
and an objective of
the organization.
What are you finding
in terms, Maureen,
in terms of young
people, the reception?
And what are you
finding in the schools?
How are the schools being
shaped by all of this?
MAUREEN COSTELLO:
What we're finding
is that schools are not
immune to the climate that
is pervasive in the United
States Teaching Tolerance
has always operated to
reduce prejudice in schools
and to improve intergroup
relations among students.
And we've always heard
about hate incidents.
Starting in 2016,
we became aware
that there were more
incidents happening
as a result of the rhetoric
of the presidential campaign,
and we surveyed teachers.
And as a result, we came
out with two reports in 2016
that showed three
alarming phenomena.
The first, of course,
was that teachers
were reporting that marginalized
students, whether they
be immigrants, LGBT students,
students of color generally,
religious minorities, were
feeling high levels of anxiety.
And that has been supported
by subsequent studies,
one out of UCLA last
year, that have just
said this has continued.
The second finding
was that bullying,
which has been a long
standing concern of educators,
had taken on a kind
of political tint,
and that we might consider
that politics had weaponized
bullying in a way, and that
the kind of rhetoric that
was being mentioned
in political campaigns
was now being used against
vulnerable students.
And the third thing we
found was that teachers
were really, really uncertain
about how to handle this--
not only about how to support
marginalized children,
how to contain the hate that
they were seeing emerging,
and, finally, even how to talk
about politics and the election
in a way that would
itself not seem partisan.
We've been tracking hate
incidents at schools.
And by hate
incidents at schools,
we're not talking about
hate crimes necessarily.
We're talking about harassment,
disparaging remarks,
negative behaviors that
target a group of people
based on their identity.
It's very hard to say
whether they have increased
because no one really was
tracking this very closely
prior to the last
couple of years.
But what we've seen is a
regular number of incidents.
And as the FBI hate crime data
showed, 25% of the hate crimes
happened in schools
from K through college.
We're about to release a report
next month in which we've
looked at both news
reports of hate incidents
and also data gathered
from educators.
And what we can tell you is that
anti-Semitism is on the rise.
Racial harassment
is on the rise.
Anti-immigrant, anti-LGBT,
anti-Muslim harassment are all
happening at schools with a
terribly detrimental effect
on students, most of whom--
over 51%-- are
children of color,
and they come from these
marginalized groups.
So obviously, this is not only
a public health crisis of sorts,
but also a problem
about making schools
effective in doing what
they're supposed to do,
which is educate.
You cannot educate when
children don't feel safe.
I would just leave by
saying that what we've also
discovered-- and this
will be in our report--
is that the vast majority of
incidents at schools never get
reported in the news media,
that probably fewer than 5%
are reported.
And that for many,
many children,
they're being exposed
to hateful language
and to disparaging remarks
in a hostile environment
in the very place where
they should feel safest.
PHILLIP MARTIN: In the last two
years, as probably especially,
you've seen a lot of kids
being emboldened, of chants,
of all types of things that
perhaps you hadn't seen before.
I don't think we could
divorce a lot of this
from the political atmosphere.
And to that end, I'd
like to turn to Jim,
who we're talking to remotely.
He's out in Wisconsin.
Jim, as former attorney
general, as a former governor,
what role are you
seeing in terms
of the law, but, more
importantly, politics,
in promulgating and
then propagating hate?
JIM DOYLE: Well,
first on the law,
let me say I argued before the
United States Supreme Court
in the 1990s the
first case that went
to them on hate
crimes in which they
upheld the right of a state--
the ability of a state to impose
harsher sanctions on people
that commit crimes
motivated by racial,
gender, other kinds of biases.
And it was a big
win at the time.
But I think we all have to
recognize that the law--
and it's critical, I should
say, that those laws be enforced
and people understand
that the law
is on one side of this issue.
It's not on the other side--
that the law is on the side
that people ought to be able
to live freely in this country,
and they ought to
live freely in a way
that they are not harassed,
harmed because of their race,
their religion, their sexual
orientation, whatever.
But we ought to recognize
that the law is--
for the issues that
have been talked about,
the demeaning statements
in schools, the low-level,
street-level interaction between
a police officer and somebody
on the street that
can be so demeaning,
that have the kind of harms
that Professor Williams has
documented--
that the law is a
pretty ham-fisted way
to deal with those.
It doesn't really
get to those kinds
of very significant issues.
That's where politics
becomes so important
and where leadership
becomes so important.
Much of this-- and I'd be
interested to see while
it's accelerated--
if I recall the statistics
from the Anti-Defamation
and Southern Poverty Law
Institute and others--
it really started
with the election
of Barack Obama and
this virulent reaction
by segments of our
society, the idea
that an African-American
person could
be president of
the United States,
birthers, and all of that racist
stuff that came out of it.
And now it's obviously
been accelerated,
why political leadership
that talks in stereotypes,
and that's what's so harmful.
These horrible stereotypes that
that brown people coming across
the borders are criminals,
that African-American people--
the stereotypes they've
dealt with in my world
of law enforcement.
It's been so harmful
as there's somehow
some kind of
inherent criminality
that we all have to
be very scared about
that is existing there.
Those kinds of large
stereotypes that
come from political
leadership from our president.
Let's just say it.
I'm mean, when you
have a president that
talks in terms of people and
these kinds of groups instead
of Americans as
American, citizens
as immigrants as individual
people with hopes and dreams,
most good, some bad.
When we have some who lump--
who sees the world in these--
and talks about it in that way.
And then you have the
obvious, when politicians
start drawing equivalencies
that what happened in Virginia
was equal on both sides.
That has a horrible effect
on our political atmosphere,
but what concerns me is what
Professor Williams was talking
about is the effect
on people that
hear that coming at them,
an African-American student
working hard in school,
trying to get ahead,
who hears leadership
talking about the people
of African-American
backgrounds with that kind
of dismissive attitude.
It has terrible,
harmful effects,
and it does in the law, as well,
because these attitudes do then
pervade the policing
on our streets and lead
to some of the terrible
incidents we've seen.
But even more the lower level--
I shouldn't say more
but equally important
that lower level, that kind
of routine stop on the street
in which a young black person
is treated in a particularly
aggressive way that a young
white person might not
has very serious effects on
how people see the government,
how they relate
to the government,
how they see the
political process,
whether they see it
as something that's
out there to try to help them.
So, obviously, my one question
I often ask is when I hear--
I've heard the president
and others say,
I'm tired of all this
political correctness.
why can't we just say
what we want to say?
And my question is, what is
it you really want to say?
why don't you just tell us
what you really want to say?
Let's get this out there.
But that's really what we're
dealing with, with a lot of--
and, politically, I
think, with the issues
that we're talking here today.
PHILLIP MARTIN: Well, one
of the things I'd like to do
is even explore this--
we might not have the time to
do it here-- but even explore
the term political correctness.
What does that mean
usually and often?
And the other point
that you just made--
and I want to address this to
our panel in a few minutes--
is that about the
role of the president.
It's the elephant in
the room, but it's one
that I think we have to explore.
Before we do that, I want to
turn to another clip, this one
by Teaching Tolerance.
This is a clip of a part
of a film they put together
called Mix It Up at Lunch.
GIRL: Mix it up day
was a very fun day.
I got to see more people
mingling and getting along
with people that they usually
don't necessarily talk to
or even look at.
And it was a very
fun thing to see
that people were being
proactive and getting
in there with other kids.
WOMAN: I loved the whole day
even though it seemed chaotic.
I loved everything
they did because it's
our kids speaking to our
kids, which is what we need.
We need interaction
between our students
so that they understand.
And, hopefully, even
though they took it
as acting or just
singing, they'll
go home tonight,
or this afternoon,
or even think about it tomorrow,
you know, what they said
really will make a
difference if I just stand up
or if I learn that I'm
different from somebody else,
and it's OK.
And that's my
message that I hope
they perceive from
today, whether it
be today or tomorrow.
But I think the whole thing
was a shining moment for me,
just to have them involved
and work with each other.
GIRL: My advice to
give to other students
is to keep their eyes
open, don't shut off
and jump to conclusions, to just
participate because I promise
it's very rewarding in the end.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHILLIP MARTIN: Well,
that's a good idea.
[LAUGHTER]
PHILLIP MARTIN: Now
we're going to mix it
up and right before my
second favorite meal lunch.
And, Maureen, let's
start off with you.
And this, obviously,
is part of an effort
to counter the hate and the type
of intolerance we're seeing out
there.
Can you talk about other
aspects of Teaching Tolerance's
programs and how you're
reaching or attempting
to reach young people much
like the local program Facing
History and Ourselves?
MAUREEN COSTELLO: We
work through teachers
across the United States
and millions of them
turn to Teaching
Tolerance for advice,
and guidance, and curriculum.
And while we do sponsor
Mix It Up at Lunch Day,
we're very cognizant of the
fact that this can't just
be a moment in the school year,
that, in fact, schools are
incredibly important places.
They're crucibles for
building the society
that we're all going to live
in in 10 years or 20 years,
and they are also one of
the last common institutions
standing.
And so I think that
it's a time that
calls for more investment in
making sure that schools are
doing their jobs to counter hate
and to build that good society.
What does that mean?
All of our work is
guided by something
we call the social
justice standards,
and they're based on four
pillars, identity, diversity,
justice, and action.
The idea of identity
in our vision
is that schools should have this
at the center of their vision
so that, as they look
at students who come in,
they want every student to find
in school a place where their
own identities-- whatever
those identities are,
be they religious, racial,
sexual orientation,
whatever-- can be affirmed and
basically that they can have
positive identity development.
Secondly, that they
develop a curiosity--
and obviously have
exposure-- to people
with different
identities, but that it's
a healthy open-minded
curiosity of, I know who I am.
Tell me who you are.
The third is we want children
to have a commitment to justice,
and that shouldn't be
very controversial.
I mean, it is part of
the Pledge of Allegiance,
that we want justice for all.
And we want children
to be able to think
critically and recognize
injustice when they see it.
And, finally, we feel that
the end of all education
has to be a capacity
to take action,
to work with others
to address injustices
and to do the work that
we're all called upon to do,
which is to make this world a
better place than we found it.
And so for us, it's about
encouraging peer relationships.
It's about encouraging
schools to have
daily interactions between--
among students and adults
that bring them together.
It's curriculum based,
explicit curriculum
about prejudice and
about stereotypes
but also that builds community,
implicit curriculum that
exposes students to the
lived experiences of others.
This is incredibly
important, and there's
lots of good research
that has shown that when
students learn about the
history of discrimination, they,
in fact--
their attitudes, their
discriminatory attitudes
decline and decrease.
So we should be honest in
our curriculum about the warp
and the flaws in our history.
And, finally, I think the most
important thing-- and school
leadership is incredibly
important here-- not
every school in this country
is a cauldron of hatred.
We hear from a lot of
teachers who talk about,
how this doesn't
happen in my school,
and they always point
to school leadership
who really walk the walk as
well as talking the talk.
Kids learn from adults, and
they learn from each other.
And so what matters
is not only what
we say but also what we do.
And that means that we have
to greet every person who
comes into that
school and treat them
as a deserving human being
who deserves our respect.
PHILLIP MARTIN:
It's funny but when
I'm thinking about the
whole notion of trying
to engender empathy--
which is what your
program does, which
is what the world of
difference program does--
you're also dealing, however,
with a larger message that's
coming across, for
example, and oftentimes,
on Twitter of a huge megaphone
that certain individuals have
in order to promulgate
a particular message.
And one question I
would have for Oren,
in the context of that, is how
do you basically get to a point
where you think you're reaching
where you actually are making
a world of difference,
when you have that bigger
megaphone out there that might
be drowning out your message.
OREN SEGAL: Yeah, I mean this
is a battle for hearts and minds
at the end of the day.
So in the Center
on Extremism, we
believe sunlight is
the best disinfectant.
You need to expose
the extremists.
You need to expose the hate
so that people can frankly
understand what
they're up against.
But our work would
not be enough without
our educational resources.
So a World of
Difference, for example,
it trains not only students
but teachers and their parents,
not only how to identify bias--
we're good at-- we're
pretty good at identifying
what is racism,
anti-Semitism, what
is Islamophobia, et cetera.
But you know what's
more important?
And this is a lesson
from the Holocaust
is to have people
to say, I'm not just
going to sit around and
do nothing about it.
You're training
kids, and, often,
this is peer-to-peer model,
as well, that we have at ADL.
And that gives it a
little bit more legitimacy
for younger people.
But to say, you
have a stake here.
You have a role.
We will teach you
how to identify bias
within institutions, within
others, and within yourself.
And then we are going
to arm you and help
you to speak out and challenge
that bias and that racism.
That makes my job
as somebody who's
tracking extremism
easier because I
know there's an
army behind me who
are going to be able to call it
out and do something about it.
Deborah Lipstadt
said anti-Semitism
starts with the Jews, but it
doesn't end with the Jews.
The same is true for
all forms of hate,
and look no further
than Pittsburgh,
where here's an individual
who attacked 11 people largest
massacre against Jews in
this country's history.
And it was motivated by an
anti-immigrant sentiment,
talking about the caravan,
talking about the social media
hate of that day,
and he targeted Jews
because in his conspiratorial
white supremacist worldview,
the Jews are controlling
our immigration policy.
So by teaching kids of
all different backgrounds,
religious, races,
et cetera, that
helps to the fight
against anti-Semitism.
And the fight
against anti-Semitism
helps fight all forms
of racism and bigotry.
That's what we're trying to
teach our kids in our schools.
PHILLIP MARTIN: Oren, and just
as a good segue way to David.
You know how to talk
about this stuff.
All of you, you're
conversationalists.
David, a lot of your research is
based on the conversations that
take place between individuals
and the amelioration
of discrimination as a
result of those discussions.
Talk about that work
and what conclusions
are you coming to in this
age of heightened anxiety
and hate, if you will?
DAVID WILLIAMS: I think
we need, as a society,
to find safe places
where people can talk.
When if someone, because
of their background
and understanding,
said something
that was inappropriate, they're
not castigated and excluded.
So I think creating those
safe places generically
is one thing that all of us
need to be because there's
a sense in which--
Kellogg Foundation had a
program called the Truth, Racial
Healing & Transformation.
People need-- don't assume that
everyone has the same level
of knowledge that you have.
And there's a term in
their socialization
that was used that didn't
think it was a problem,
and they're now
learning it's a problem.
So I think we need to be
patient with each other
but be committed to firmly
but lovingly raise its use
and provide truth.
There is a study I
want to talk about it.
It was published recently,
very elegant study
published in Science, where
a group of researchers
took political canvases
and sent them out
to Democratic and
Republican voters
and had these canvassers allow
the voter they were talking
to to do most of the talking.
And their job was to find
ways to link an experience
in the life of the canvasser to
think of some experience they
had had when they had
been treated negatively
and then to link that to how
transgender individuals would
feel when they are
treated negatively.
And this showed that
this kind of conversation
was effective in reducing
prejudice against transgender
individuals, it was effective
in increasing levels of support
for policies to ensure
anti-discrimination legislation
towards transgender individuals.
And what they would
say is the key
is the specific language
and conversation that
was used to engender this.
And this organization out
in Southern California
who does this work, they tested
13,000 conversations first
to find the right
kind of conversation
that nonetheless can open the
door to help to build empathy.
And I think the building of
empathy of putting ourselves
in the shoes of another
is one of the keys
to build in the
kind of tolerance
that we need in our society.
PHILLIP MARTIN: One of
the cauldrons that we're
seeing where empathy is
basically being challenged
would contravene and it seems
to be taking place online.
I think about
Reddit, for example,
which has become a platform for
abuse and for a lot of haters.
And, Dipayan, how are
you basically finding
Reddit and other
social media platforms?
Are the conversations
that David talked about
and the efforts toward empathy--
or can they possibly take
place on online platforms
that seem to have been basically
subsumed by the haters?
DIPAYAN GHOSH: Wow, it's
very difficult, I think.
I think it's very
difficult. To cite
another study, a
different study,
MIT researchers showed
about just a few months ago
in a paper--
I believe in Science or
Nature-- that falsehoods travel
20 times faster than the truth.
And they travel faster,
they travel farther,
and they reach deeper
into social networks,
meaning to individual
people using Twitter,
which was the social network
that these researchers
analyzed.
And I think what that suggests
is that, well, falsehood,
and hate, and disinformation
are all linked together.
And in the practice of
spreading hate online,
on social networks,
or the practice
of spreading
disinformation, we've
seen over, and over,
and over, again,
that propagators of
this kind of content
are really linking
the two and trying
to hit those thin cracks
in American society
and pound them over, and over,
and over, again, and fracture
society by targeting ads, or
targeting content, or pulling
people into filter
bubbles and showering them
with content about a
particular political issue that
triggers hatred or triggers
discriminatory action going
forward.
And I think to really
resolve that kind of issue,
we have to revisit
the business model.
We have to think,
again, about how
do Facebook, Twitter,
YouTube, how do they work?
It's about these services.
It's about the
collection of data
to drive behavioral
profiling, and it's
about these algorithms that
target ads and curate content.
And to really address hate
speech in the long run,
we're seeing two issues.
We're seeing this problem
of filter bubbles which is--
I believe-- is caused by this
business model of people trying
to force people--
hate speech propagators and
disinformation operators
trying to force people
into these filter bubbles
and increase engagement
over these platforms,
as the internet
platforms themselves
want to increase
their ad revenues.
And we're seeing this
problem of pushing content
against those thin cracks to
try to break people or break
their will to be tolerant.
I think the only place
to start, then, is
to address that infrastructure.
And that's going to require
a lot of political will,
and right now if we-- we
talked earlier about politics,
these issues even as they
pertain to social media
are divided along
partisan lines.
When I worked in the White
House during the Obama
administration, we
saw this, and it
was very difficult to
do anything about it.
When I worked at Facebook in
Washington, we saw this again.
And I think it's going
to be extraordinarily
difficult to address it,
but we need political will.
We need to build
sentiment and build up
the public education on
these kinds of issues
and start to address them
looking deep down at the way
that the internet
is structured today.
PHILLIP MARTIN: Let's
take it from online
to the streets of the role, for
example, of law enforcement,
in much of what many people see
as antithetical relationship
with communities of color,
with many communities
in the country.
And then many seem
to be emboldened
by the current administration,
the Justice Department,
and by the White House.
Jim, can you talk about--
and then I'm going to
ask the panel pretty
much the same-- the panel here,
pretty much the same question--
can you talk about the role
that police officers are playing
in terms of, if you will,
the receptivity to a lot
of these negative messages
that are being, if you will,
being seen as messages of hate.
JIM DOYLE: Many more
people are going
to have contact with
a police officer
than they are with the
President of the United States.
And many-- or a governor,
or an attorney general--
and many are going to draw
their conclusions about how
the government reacts to them
over their lifetimes based
on that contact.
We have been at this for a
long time of the training,
and that's why I
really encourage
all of people who
have spoken here
about the training
they do to modernize
police training on this issue.
After Rodney King, we set
out on a large scale training
in Wisconsin, as
many states did,
on police understanding
racial divisions.
Much of the training
when I look back at it--
and I've seen the results--
was just plain wrong.
I mean, a lot of it was
police officers going up
to people to African-American
people and calling them,
man, because they
thought that was
how they were going
to relate more closely
and be part of the community.
Much of the training
and community policing
was to teach white
police officers how
to talk kind of
jive, street jive,
thinking that somehow that was
making them culturally aware
and with the people that
they were talking about.
You saw it at Harvard with
the Professor Gates incident
where a distinguished professor
is treated in that way.
We probably all know, and I
know dear relatives and friends
who have been treated--
I've often asked-- I think the
training for police officers
ought to start by having rich
African-American people come in
so they know this
isn't about poverty
and tell them about their worst
experience with the police.
And white people are shocked
to hear these stories.
I've done this a few times.
To hear to hear their
friends talk about what
happened to them when they went
in the hardware store and got
followed around and then
stopped because maybe they
were shoplifters.
So it gets back to
this empathy issue.
And much of the training
was good and, obviously,
the major part of
law enforcement
after training has to
be, this is the law,
and you have to
enforce the law, and it
doesn't matter who the person is
in front of you or their color.
But when you get into these
deeper assumptions that people
have-- and many police officers
are not immune to them--
that for some genetic
reason black people
have more criminal
disposition than white people,
that's at the heart of much of
what we're talking about here.
And that gets
reinforced politically.
So I really encourage the kind
of training we've talked about
and we've heard about in
the schools and others,
particularly about
empathy, to really
have that be the training that
moves into the law enforcement
realm as well.
I want to make one
other point if I
can about politics quickly.
We've come, unfortunately,
in this country now,
to two parties that are-- one
is almost an all-white party
and one is a party
that is made up
of most racial minority, some
white males, and about half
of the white females
in the country.
If you just look at
this demographically,
that's not a good place
for us to be politically
because the white party has
to maximize its white vote
in every election.
And the way you do that
is to get white people,
the majority people
voting as a block,
and we saw this in the South
after the Civil Rights Act.
Nobody thought in the South
that Republicans someday could
get 75% of the white vote.
They said, that'll never happen.
Well, it's happened.
And now you are seeing that same
thing happening politically.
And the result is on this--
on the messaging issue that
we've talked about--
there are political
incentives now
that are exploited, as was just
described, on the internet.
What do we know about
what the Russians did?
Some of that's come out is
they exploited racial divisions
by putting all kinds of stuff
out on the internet that both--
after police shootings--
that inflamed both sides.
That's how they know
they can get to us.
And our politics
is now driving us
into that same position
where one side benefits
from inflaming it,
and the other side
benefits by trying
to make sure that all
of the people of minority
background in the country
are voting for their party.
And we now are in a very, very
difficult political place.
We've been here for a
long time, but it has now
gotten that you just look at
the numbers, and the vote,
and how it breaks down by
race, it is just stark.
We have parties that are
divided on this issue.
PHILLIP MARTIN: I
can tell you, we
could talk about
this, folks, for days
because it's so
much to talk about.
We have time at this point
for just a few questions
from our listeners
and our viewers.
This question is from Michael
and he says, "Clearly, there
are a host of levels
that impact racism,
institutional,
cultural, et cetera,
what is our best
chance of changing
racism on an individual level?"
I'm going to direct this one
right now to David and then
to the rest of our panel.
DAVID WILLIAMS: It's
a big challenge.
I think I would say we need
to raise awareness levels.
So what's happening
with teaching tolerance
so that people
are knowledgeable.
And I would say that the media
has a powerful role to play.
We have seen-- now, I'm not
suggesting in any way, shape,
or form that we've
solved the problem--
but we have seen
striking declines
in the levels of prejudice
against LGBT populations
in the United States.
That has not happened by chance.
Much of that has been linked
in scientific research
to explicit strategies
that were implemented
in the media that has led
to reductions of prejudice.
And I think we need
to change the culture.
We need to change
what people think.
And the media and other
larger cultural institutions,
like religious institutions,
can also play an important role
in changing the very
culture around these issues.
PHILLIP MARTIN: Oren.
OREN SEGAL: Yeah, I mean-- this
was the $64,000 or the million
dollar question.
I do think this, in tracking
extremism of all types
and narratives,
especially, online,
I am always disappointed by
the lack of content that tells
the other side of the story.
So if you go onto
YouTube, and you put 9/11.
You want to learn
about what happened,
and younger people are not
quite sure what happened
because they weren't alive.
It's only a couple
of suggestions
away from conspiracy theories,
and these our more mainstream
platforms that are being
exploited by those who are
giving these false narratives.
These hate hateful narratives.
So I do think creating
an opportunity for people
to create content--
not just that counters
it, that's difficult--
but to have a place to
develop your own narratives
is part of that effort of
creating critical thinking.
Not only think about
what you're seeing
and what you're
bringing in, and think
about who's trying to fool
you, and try to trick you,
and brainwash you into
having these hateful beliefs,
but you need to have an
opportunity to then leverage
other types of content.
I learn about new
technologies from two places,
from extremists and from
my seven-year-old son.
And so we need to be able to
arm our youth with the ability
to tell their stories
in compelling ways that
are as sexy, and cool,
and interesting as those
who have those hateful ideas.
PHILLIP MARTIN: One of the
questions I do want to ask--
in the little time that we
have-- is, Maureen and Dipayan,
are you saying--
what is the impact
of what we're seeing
outside of the United States?
What impact is that
having on, if you will,
thoughts about
tolerance intolerance
here in the United States?
Out of Hungary, for
example, where you see Roma
under assault, where
you see immigrants
immigration has
become an issue that
has been defined as us
versus them like here
in the United States.
What's your view about
that, the impact?
MAUREEN COSTELLO: I don't think
that we're seeing it explicitly
on school children, for
instance, or even on educators,
but I think that a lot of the
language and the ideas that
are coming out of Europe are
being amplified in social media
here in the United States.
And nobody is paying
attention to where
they're coming from, basically.
So I think that the notion
that just because they're
across the ocean, they don't
affect those is just untrue.
DIPAYAN GHOSH: Just
to add to that,
I completely agree with
Maureen, and we're definitely
seeing some really nasty
themes come particularly
from all over Europe,
Eastern Europe, Western
Europe, and Northern
Europe, that are,
as Oren and I have researched
a little bit and spoken about,
driven from this idea
of identitarianism.
And that is definitely
shaping a lot
of cultural creation of this--
or this ethos that we are
better and they're worse.
And I think that people like
Richard Spencer and people
like that in the United
States have certainly
subsumed that message
and projected it here.
And that's obviously dangerous.
PHILLIP MARTIN: I'm
looking at our clock
and so-- but I also
need all of you
to just take a moment
to, if you will,
summarize this discussion
and your thoughts
on hatred and intolerance that's
sweeping across our nation,
unfortunately.
Oren.
OREN SEGAL: Sure, to the degree
this is a final word for me,
I would say, we have a heat map
at ADL where we track incidents
of anti-Semitism, hate
crimes, extremist activity
of all types.
And I'm always reminded,
as we're trying to explain
to the public, the
trends that we're seeing,
that each one of those points
on a map over 5,000-- now,
over the last two years--
is a story of
community resilience.
Is a story of people
coming together
and rejecting that hate.
And to your point
about the media,
I think we need to start
telling more inspiring stories.
And because when we hear
that, that also has an impact
and that also maybe creates
courage amongst people
to hold all those who are
purveyors of hate accountable,
whether they're in
your local community
or whether they're in
the highest office.
We all have a voice.
And we need to constantly
support all those
in our communities to
show that hate really
does have no place here.
So you don't do this
work for 20 years
without having some sort of hope
that things will get better.
But I think the
data, and I think
the training, whether it's for
law enforcement, students, et
cetera, will help make
those dots a little bit
more actionable.
And you're turning basically
lemons into lemonade.
DAVID WILLIAMS:
Two quick things.
Governor Doyle talked
about interactions
of African-Americans
with the police.
I and other colleagues
published a paper last year
in Lancet that shows
that when police killed
an unarmed
African-American male,
the mental health of the entire
African-American population
in that state is adversely
affected for the next three
months.
So, again, it's
another example of this
is affecting the quality of
life of individuals here.
And, finally, my
other quick point
is that this
environment of hate.
It's not only about
individual interaction.
It is driving social
policy, and we
are leaning towards policies,
the policy proposals
right now in Washington DC, that
will destroy the social safety
net as we know it today.
And we don't have to guess
about what would happen.
In 1981, the omnibus
reconciliation bill,
early in the Reagan
administration,
let a million people lost
food stamps and 600,000 people
would dropped from Medicare--
Medicaid.
And 250 community health centers
closed in the United States
as a result to cuts
to social services,
and there were pervasive
negative effects on children,
on pregnant women, on the
elderly in the United States.
So we have to look not
only at all interactions,
we have to look at the
policies that we decide
driven by false narratives.
PHILLIP MARTIN: Dipayan.
DIPAYAN GHOSH: I'll also
share just two quick thoughts.
First, addressing
the online space.
Again, I think these internet
platforms are designed
the way they are because they're
designed to increase engagement
and there's no
regulatory regime that
sits above them right now
that that tells them, no, you
can't do that. you
can't spread hate. you
can't spread discrimination.
One example, Latanya
Sweeney, a professor
of computer science here at
Harvard, searched for her name
on Google, and I
believe the story
that she reported is that
she saw an ad for jails
because Google inferred
that her name is associated
with African-American heritage
and thought that, hey, we
should show her this ad.
In another example, Google--
when kids were searching for
gorillas on Google Images--
people saw images of minorities
in the United States.
These systems are designed
to drive engagement
because they want professor
Sweeney to click on that ad
because they think that that's
going to drive engagement.
They want people to--
they design these
algorithms in ways
that encourages clicks and
encourages bigger ad spend.
So my first point is that we
need to address that system.
We need our leadership
to understand
how these systems work and start
to address them at their core.
Second point is
just a broader one
which is that I think
our leaders, in society,
from politicians to
actors and actresses,
thought leaders need to be more
honest and need to speak up.
I think, just one example--
this didn't come up yet--
but with Liam Neeson,
we've seen over
the past few days.
I want to highlight
not just what
he said, which was honest to
the public, which I appreciate
at some level, but also
what a soccer player,
John Barnes of African origin
but who played in England,
his reaction to Liam Neeson.
And his reaction was one
of great appreciation
for the honesty, instead of
just the traditional media
reaction which was that,
wow, Liam Neeson is
a horrible person, and
we need to vilify him.
So I would appreciate
more honesty.
We've seen that in
the US Congress,
as well, over the past week.
So just two quick
points, thank you.
PHILLIP MARTIN: Maureen.
MAUREEN COSTELLO:
I think we're going
to win or lose this battle
in the schools, basically.
If we do not orient our
schools towards the vision
that they are, in fact,
building the society that we're
going to live in in the
future, we have lost.
We've been focusing a lot in
schools on college and career
readiness, and we really have
to focus on social and emotional
readiness, as well.
My ideal-- the
ideal policy change
is to really make integration
a focus of our school policy.
But if we can't
go there, then we
really need to make sure
that young people have
digital intelligence so
that they know not only
how to interpret material that
comes to them as consumers,
but that they also learn how
to be productive consumers--
producers for social media.
I think at the end of the day,
I'm reminded of the phrase
that Dr. King used in
his last book, which
is that we have a choice
between chaos and community.
And what we've been talking
about so much is isolation.
Hate grows in isolation.
And schools are
places of community.
And so everything that we need
to do is deliberate talking--
teaching about the kind of
discrimination that exists,
not pretending it doesn't
exist, admitting that we've all
been socialized to be racists.
And I think it's particularly
an issue in schools
because 80% of teachers
are white women.
And I'm very fond
of white women.
[LAUGHTER]
But they carry
with them-- we all
carry with us implicit biases.
It's one of the issues that
a lot of good police training
has tried to address,
and it's something
we have to address
with teachers as well.
But we really,
really need to decide
that this next
generation has to be
better than we are generally.
PHILLIP MARTIN: And, Jim,
in Wisconsin, please,
your last words.
Well, not your last words.
[LAUGHTER]
Your words today.
JIM DOYLE: Well, I
agree with everything
that's just been said.
I had a friend, a European,
say to me recently,
whatever happened
to your country?
And he went off about
how bad everything was.
I said, well, remember,
this is a country
that, just a few
years ago, you were
cheering because of the election
of Barack Obama as president.
And it's not like
everybody just suddenly
moved out of this country
and a whole new group,
new people moved in.
But what happened is we
are a complicated country.
And while we've talked
about the problems here,
we are a country
of great tolerance
and of acceptance, and in our
schools, and churches, and much
of the work that's
being done here.
The police officers
all across the country
are doing really, really
important things on this.
So I'm going to end this if
I could just politically,
which is in Wisconsin--
and we weren't unique--
in this last
election, in November,
we had more people vote
in an off-year election
than at any time since
the Second World War
and a massive turnout
at presidential levels.
And it was a very,
very close vote,
and, I will say the
person I wanted to win won
but that's beside the point.
The point is we do have a very,
very engaged political world
right now.
And all of the
education we've talked
about, the issues
of implicit bias,
of tolerance, the more we talk
about that in all the ways
we've talked about here
today really affect
how current voters and
younger people who are going
to be coming voters will vote.
And that's how in a democracy--
back to Professor
Williams' comments
about the policies that
make the difference-- that's
how we try to make
sure the policies
we want are effectuated.
And so it is really critical
that we have a very, very
engaged political body and
I'll give President Trump
credit for this-- he has truly
engaged the American people.
And we are seeing voting turnout
like we have never seen before,
and that's a good thing.
And that, politically, is the
way you address these issues.
PHILLIP MARTIN: Jim, thank
you, and on that note.
And on that note,
I want to thank
our panel, Jim, Maureen,
Dipayan, you know David,
and Oren.
And I'd like to thank
you, our audience,
for taking part in this forum.
Let me mention also
something that's coming up
on March 4, another event.
And I'm going to read this.
This is the Dr. Lawrence
and Roberta Cohn
forum, it's deaths from
pregnancy and childbirth,
why are more US mothers
dying and what can be done?
This was also presented jointly
by PRI's The World and WGBH.
I'd like to thank you, and
I'd like to thank our panel.
Engaging discussion.
There's a lot of work
to be done, obviously,
but you've begun that work
and you are carrying out
that work every day.
Thank you very much.
And I thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]